my anger toward Paul grew into a hatred
of all men I began to reject the gender
binary Itself by 2016 I identified as
trans
[Music]
in college
I was sexually assaulted by a classmate
named Paul ashamed I only told a few
friends
I didn't even call the police
My Friends gossiped word spread one
night
a classmate approached me and said she'd
heard what happened Paul had done the
same to her
she'd even heard about other women
I reached out to them for confirmation
there were six of us
each silenced by her own brand of Shame
determined to put a stop to Paul's
violence and protect prospective victims
we reported him to the school and the
police
he never even got a slap on the wrist
this was before the metoo movement back
when we the survivors of rape
were assumed to be the criminals
hysterical women crying wolf
amidst the tumult I was nominated for an
Arts fellowship at Yale University which
I won this was huge
art was my passion
when I had first learned in school about
artworks That Changed History I became
determined
to make one too confident
that with hard work I too could expand
the scope of Art
as a fellowship recipient I was granted
Studio space in Connecticut over summer
break
I was thrilled to get out of town and
away from the drama in New York
out in Connecticut I could make anything
I wanted
unencumbered by my professors
assignments
for no particular reason I found an
unused room in a house on the property
and filmed myself dancing in it
the product was relatively boring
to shake things up I asked a friend to
film me preparing for the video
recording it
and resetting everything once I was done
One Moment In the resulting footage
caught my eye
when I was struggling to carry the bed
out of the room
I wanted to explore it further
I asked her to film me again but this
time I would bring it all the way out of
the house
I realized that the mattress might
represent the weight of what I'd endured
evoking how it feels to bring something
intimate out of the bedroom and into the
light
the one remaining dissonance was at my
assault had happened on a college campus
while the video depicted me in the
middle of nowhere
I realized that to perfect this piece I
would have to carry the mattress
like the one on which I had been
assaulted when I got back to Colombia
while honing the final form of what
would become mattress performance carry
that weight
I took inspiration from the year-long
endurance works of my favorite
performance artist
for example in one he locked himself in
a cage for a year
I loved the meditative quality of
embarking on a journey that took such
internal resolve
I was curious to see how I myself might
change over the course of my final year
of college if I committed to carrying
the mattress every everywhere I went
gaining physical and emotional strength
as I overcame my pain
I did not expect my performance to cause
a stir beyond the Columbia Community
however by the end of the first day
camera Crews were trailing me everywhere
overnight I became the figurehead of the
incipient movement to end sexual assault
on college campuses worldwide
I was featured on the covers of the New
York Times and New York Magazine
I received a standing ovation led by
Gloria Steinem
I was a guest at President Obama's State
of the Union speech
I was trolled I got death threats I was
reviled by individuals on both ends of
the political Spectrum
one article written by a journalist
named Kathy young was particularly
destructive
Kathy worked with Paul to splice our
Facebook messages and make it look like
I'd asked him to quote me in the
ass
in reality I'd said something like I
have to wake up early in the morning
me in the ass in the way that
someone might say shoot me in the head
without actually wanting to be murdered
the fact that a full-grown adult
felt compelled to manipulate the truth
and cause a stupid 21 year old like
myself so much suffering seemed like
proof that the political right in my
country was both Petty and malicious
meanwhile
the left showered me with praise and
awards which increasingly aligned me and
obliged me to Champion my party's social
causes
my frustration with Colombia and the
police became a rejection of all
institutions
my anger toward Paul grew into a hatred
of all men
I began to reject the gender binary
Itself by 2016 I identified as trans
while I fully support individuals who
need other pronouns to affirm their
gender identity I personally no longer
need them myself
by the time the metoo movement gained
widespread popularity in 2017. I was
under so much media fueled scrutiny
that I hardly recognized myself
art
the place where I had once felt free to
experiment play and express my ambition
had become a straight jacket
I was having repeated panic attacks
thank God I met Dylan Marin the host of
a podcast that I'd never heard of called
conversations with people who hate me
Dylan wanted me to be a guest on his
show
his plan was to contact one of my online
detractors and moderate a conversation
between us
we picked a rather benign one named
Benjamin who sent me a Facebook message
calling me a liar
most episodes of conversations with
people who hate me result in the
participants gaining Newfound
appreciation for one another
my conversation with Benjamin ended
differently
he basically grilled me and I felt
backed into a corner my final words were
so yeah I'm definitely going away from
this conversation feeling a little like
I'll never have the kind of resolution I
wanted and you know it's always sad
because it's like I never wanted to be
raped in the first place
and I never wanted to be here at all so
yeah I'm coming away from this
conversation a little heartbroken and I
guess I hope that this conversation ends
up meaning something to someone someday
when the episode went live it caused
such an uproar that Benjamin started
receiving hatred from strangers too
this instigated a follow-up episode in
which Dylan moderated a conversation
between Benjamin and a woman named Kay
who'd commented on Facebook Ben if
you're reading this I hope you're eaten
alive by wild dogs
this time around Benjamin sounded like a
new person in the month since we had
talked he had listened to our episode
five times
he was ready to approach the subject of
sexual assault with an open mind
Benjamin's transformation reminded me
that change doesn't happen overnight and
there's no use in feeling upset when
people don't change their minds as
quickly as we'd like
that summer I was single
and I matched with a guy who'd super
liked me on Tinder
we've entered and decided to meet up
before our date I stalked him on Twitter
and saw that he was conservative
a past version of me would have ended it
there
however my experience with Dylan's
podcast made me wonder whether we might
at the very least have an interesting
conversation
I texted him that it might be quote
interesting Progressive powerful for two
people who might be the antithesis of
each other to go on a Tinder date later
the wonderful journalist Sylvie McNamara
wrote a viral article for New York Times
about this part of my story
she spoke with my date and asked him if
he had a preferred pseudonym
he picked Chad which was as she put it a
reference to the in-cell term used for
men who due to serendipitous genetics
are attractive enough to have Oodles of
sex and Chad is a chad
ahead of our date Chad sent me some
articles he'd publish and I sent him
some documents regarding my work he
expected me to be and here I quote him
the patron saint of wokeness but he was
pleasantly surprised to find that I was
more complex
following the date I asked him to
recommend one book to help me understand
him better and he picked the Righteous
Mind by Jonathan height
in it Jonathan discusses the
sociological roots of our society's
tendency toward political tribalism
he emphasizes the importance of learning
from one another's beliefs
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas